one thing that absolutely delights me is
republican infighting fight amongst
yourselves please today our deep dive
into the grand old party not getting
along with each other
uh one of the real questions
that we are going to
answer merely by observing the american
political landscape for the next i think
in the next few months it will become
clear
is whether the
sparks
of a republican civil war that we saw
two months ago
will turn into a fire
and there are sort of two possible paths
forward
it's conceivable that right-wing media
and the republican party will realize
whoa
we are in real rough shape trump lost
the house for us in 2018.
trump lost the senate for us in 2020.
trump lost the white house for us in
2020 we have nothing
so we have to unite we can't have a
republican civil war where right-wing
media and elected officials are on
opposing sides and even within the
republican party there could be a civil
war between people like mitt romney uh
and people like lauren bobo bobert or
marjorie taylor green right so there's a
number of different civil wars that that
could take place the alternative is that
there is a republican civil war where
one side of the republican party accuses
the other of not having stood behind
trump enough
of being willing to compromise with joe
biden whatever
and that we see a a civil war develop
sean hannity earlier this week signaled
that he is at least willing to foment
this civil war
uh apparently turning on mitch mcconnell
and threatening the he at the time he
was the senate majority leader
now he's the senate minority leader
thanks to democrats taking control of
the senate take a listen to this
mitch i will give you an a plus on
getting constitutionalist judges on the
bench been great on judges but frankly
it looks like it's time now if you're
going to go along with all of this
nonsense we need new leadership in the
u.s senate you can represent the people
of kentucky you're showing basically
right now that you're the king of the
establishment republicans that frankly
have always had and remain having
contempt
for president trump and more importantly
the 75 million americans that voted for
him
americans want somebody that will fight
for their values and principles not
scheme behind closed doors with your
buddy chuckie schumer very republican in
the senate so much like with maria
bartiromo
sean hannity's direct line to the
president ended yesterday with the
inauguration of joe biden he knows
biden's not going to take his calls like
trump did so hannity wants to stay
relevant in some way and what's going on
here is that hannity believes he's still
the decision maker and the influence
peddler now he may be he may find a way
to maintain that role even though he
doesn't uh speak to to the president
anymore it would be really great for the
left to have a battle between right-wing
media and republicans
that that is only good for the left and
it's just what joe biden needs to get
going with some momentum republicans so
busy with infighting
that they are unable to uh obstruct the
things that joe biden wants to do to
clean up trump's mess and um
one other funny thing you know by
hannity talks about maybe we need new
leadership in the senate
there is new leadership in the senate
because democrats won the senate and
hannity of course means new republican
leadership uh but the the new senate
leadership is democrats all together and
this is going to be very very
interesting now
for people saying that uh i'm somehow
being hypocritical on this
i'm not i have said before a divided
democratic party with infighting is bad
for democrats
and a divided republican party is bad
for republicans the difference is i want
the republican party to be divided
because it will be bad for them i didn't
want the democratic party to be divided
because it was going to be bad for the
left-wing movement and so i'm consistent
infighting is bad i just am going to
benefit
from republican infighting and thus i'm
fine with them doing that send me your
thoughts and we'll continue to monitor
this over the next few days this is a
fascinating segment that goes to the
limits of political loyalty because
there are some trump supporters whose
undying support for trump has no limit
but for some trump supporters their
support of trump does have a limit and
that limit is called the coronavirus
vaccine you're gonna be
probably horrified by these clips
after a year of donald trump telling his
own supporters that the pandemic isn't
serious
calling it the china virus that you
don't need a vaccine
some of those trump supporters now don't
want the vaccine they see the vaccine as
liberal nonsense especially as they see
joe biden as the one who is so quickly
accelerating vaccination
nearly three million doses the last two
days we'll talk about that tomorrow but
that's very good news so cnn sends their
reporter gary tuckman to a diner in
boise city oklahoma and it is compelling
video this county was a 92 percent trump
county back in november
but right now we have some conflicting
numbers we know that most republican
voters still like trump but about half
of republicans don't want the vaccine as
of last week trump now recommends to his
followers that they get the vaccine so
we have a statistical conflict
they mostly like trump who's saying get
the vaccine but half of them don't want
the vaccine how does this conflict
manifest
gary tuckman asks the diners questions
about the vaccine it got awkward and
very ignorant let's take a look at the
first clip it's breakfast time in boise
city oklahoma
and i have this question does anybody in
this restaurant think it's a good idea
to take the vaccine
raise your hand if you think it's a good
idea
anyone here is a good idea to take the
vaccine raise your hand if you think
it's a good idea
not one person here thinks is a good
idea
complete quiet so that's already not so
good
and then gary tuckman speaks to some
specific people and here i would get the
kids out of the room for this this is
ugly ugly stuff that we're about to see
take a look what do you think about the
vaccine are you going to take the
vaccine no sir tell me why well i don't
trust the government and i don't trust
biden chad and misty hughes are husband
and wife
neither of them plan to get the vaccine
just don't want to
why don't you want to if you don't mind
me asking because when i take the flu
shot i usually get the flu so
there's no reason to take it are you
saying you think you'll get covered by
taking the cocaine
are you why are you thinking that the
research doesn't show that at all it
shows that it keeps people safe that's
just my choice so that first guy is bad
enough who says i don't trust the
government or biden because remember the
vaccine was developed not because of
trump but it was developed during
trump's administration trump is taking
credit for it trump's people initially
oversaw
the initial distribution which was
completely abortive but still like the
first guy doesn't care now joe biden is
president now is when that guy could get
a vaccine and he doesn't trust the
government or joe biden but the second
guy
the flu shot usually gives me the flu it
can't happen it's impossible doesn't
happen
so i will assume that the covet vaccine
will give me covet that's not
necessarily a trump biden thing that's
total vaccine ignorance that appears to
go beyond politics although it seems to
still exist more on the right than on
the left let's look at another one of
these absolutely horrifying clips these
women are sisters and they too are
doubters why are you doubtful
they just started rolling them out
well yeah but they've i mean this has
been a worldwide effort by great claim
that the flu can be cured but still
hundreds of thousands of people die from
the flu well yes a lot of people
definitely but not nearly as much as
covent this is a horrible pandemic and
this is like
amazing vaccine these vaccines have come
out they're saving lives
i will just agree to disagree on this
subject i guess
i just i'm just not i'm not going to
take it she said they claim the flu can
be cured
but people still die of the flu despite
having a vaccine so this is like it's
the brain is
it's is it putty
is it uh i don't know what to call it no
one claims the flu vaccine cures flu the
idea is the flu vaccine prevents flu in
some and in others it makes it less
severe but the flu vaccines are not
nearly as effective as these coronavirus
vaccines are and if you wonder how does
someone get tricked by trump
into believing he's going to build a
wall
and that mexico will pay for it that'll
fix trade that he'll put in a beautiful
health care plan
these are the same people that believe
the flu shot will give you the flu
right
these are the people we're talking about
that fell for that stuff and were
tricked into voting for donald trump
here's another clip
what if president trump came out and was
very robust and said take the vaccine i
took it even though i didn't tell
anybody about it was kind of done
secretly but i think you should take it
he said it a little bit but he hasn't
been robust about it he was robust and
said take it would you
no trump's a liberal new yorker why
would we listen to him
either did you vote for him
he was the best option
what's funny about that trump voter who
says
trump's a liberal new yorker why would i
listen to him anyway
that antipathy that came out there that
that cultural clash
the diners in oklahoma are like
this guy trump in the end is just like a
rich liberal new yorker
that exists on trump's behalf as well
and what i mean by that is
the vast majority of trump supporters as
i've said so many times
are the types of people that donald
trump spent his life trying to stay away
from
so it's fascinating stuff
but it is very disturbing to see these
clips and some of what these folks talk
about you know it's like what's more
dangerous getting covert of the vaccine
the answer is obvious getting covet is
far more dangerous than any side effects
you would have from the vaccine another
question is what's more dangerous
getting the virus or being that ignorant
like what other risks to their lives
exist
or are created because of the degree of
ignorance that they exhibit during
interviews like this it is wacky wacky
stuff and you know i told the story last
week of i've spent time in rural
northern indiana
and while i don't agree with the
political views of the people there
seeing it and seeing how basically you
grow up in a church and on a gun range
that's what there is in northern indiana
being told that guns and abortion are
the two most important things
of course you're not voting for
democrats because you're for 18 years by
the time you can vote and longer by the
time you know you're older
that's all that you that's all that's
there and that's all that that is your
experience of course you're not going to
vote for joe biden based on what what is
publicly said we have to understand
these folks because as ignorant as they
are if they don't get vaccinated it's
bad for all of us and um unfortunately
the the sort of ignorance is bliss type
of thing
it may work for them but it's still
dangerous for many others so interesting
interesting segment there gary tuckman
with cnn don't forget that the best way
to support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
alright so i alluded to this earlier you
have to see the level of chaos that the
mark meadows trump riot texts are
causing in right-wing media so let me
reset the story for you first and then
we're going to just jump into something
i i it's genuinely delightful i don't
know how else to describe it earlier
this week republican congresswoman liz
cheney member of the house committee
investigating the january 6 riots
read a bunch of text messages
reportedly sent from fox news hosts and
donald trump jr to trump's then chief of
staff mark meadows
and despite going on air that day and
for weeks downplaying the riots it might
have been antifa it was blm it wasn't
real trump supporters i didn't actually
see any trump supporter being violent as
well as trump's own son
and all of these fox news hosts doing
that on that day they knew it was
terrible and they knew it was trump's
problem and they were trying to get
trump on tv to make a statement tell him
to send everybody home it exposes that
everything they did after the fact was
just dishonest cleanup and they knew
exactly who was there that day and that
it was very bad for donald donald trump
period they knew it they lied on tv to
help trump no surprise it's been
confirmed
now
all of the different factions are
starting to go at each other because
they don't know how to manage this last
night sean hannity one of the people
implicated in this entire fiasco had a
segment
where he invited on geraldo rivera
um and this total right-wing nut dan
bongino who just defends trump always
and forever there's no situation where
bongino won't defend trump and geraldo
even though he you know was a trump
supporter is a friend of trump whatever
geraldo actually stands up sort of for
what's right and says to hannity listen
because hannity is continuing to
downplay the riots he says this was a
riot
it was inspired by trump supporters
period
and hannity tries to interrupt and her
also says wait a second sean
think back to when you sent those texts
think back to your frame of mind when
you realized
these are trumpists doing this and this
is violent and this is terrible and you
texted mark meadows think back to that
and bongino just loses it on geraldo
check this out was the obvious
difference between the riot that
happened on january 6th and the 500 odd
that you correctly cite as concerning
and and and damaging to america to our
psyche to our our physical well-being is
that this was a riot that was unleashed
incited and inspired by the president of
the united states which targeted we're
not talking about
american democracy the president didn't
say no you could target the
president said
no no stop the president said peacefully
patriotically march to the capitol
that's your opinion i don't even want to
go down that road that's not the
question tonight the question is this
corrupt committee the question is why
this riot and not 574 other rights the
question is is there any privacy in this
country anymore or do they get to
release thousands more of individual
private citizens tax
i beg you sean
to remember the frame of mind you were
in when you wrote that text on january
6th and when laura did and when brian
did and when don jr did remember the
concern you had remember the the
frustration
at our our beloved 45th president yeah
because i wanted to see how to write can
he be doing this why doesn't he say
something why okay
but the point is he did you saw
unfolding before you he saw unfolding
and then he did do it dan you have less
than a minute we're running out of time
haraldo we've been arguing about this
forever the backstabbing of the
president you're engaging in is really
disgusting and it's really vile that you
pretend to be this guy representing you
i resent that i supported
donald trump
you leave it there and you stab them in
the back you heard it thank you thank
you both so it's not backstabbing
it's telling the truth geraldo is saying
nothing controversial it was a trumpist
riot sean hannity knew it and texted
mark meadows at the time to try to stop
it and now he's playing a completely
different version of events on tv
day in and day out that's really it like
there's no more story and hannity pulls
in bongino to run interference and
they're starting to just go after each
other geraldo is no sage
right when geraldo is the voice of
reason you know things have gotten a
little bit wacky but this is what you
want to see this committee has already
done so much good
in all that it is exposed and all these
people are more than willing to go after
each other to save themselves remember
that
if republicans had just gone along with
the original committee
it is far less likely that all of this
same damaging information would have
come out why do i say that well the
original committee idea was
i believe these are the right numbers
five democrats five republicans
when they would send out subpoenas
the subpoenas would have to be signed
off on
not only by the democratic chair of the
committee but by the republican vice
chair of the committee
it was going to be truly a committee
that was not just going to have carte
blanche to go fishing wherever they want
republicans and i'm not saying that
that's what it is now but republicans
said we're not going to participate
we're protesting this entire thing
unless we're also looking into you know
the shooting of steve scalise four years
ago or whatever else we don't want to
participate so nancy pelosi found some
republicans willing to be on it liz
cheney's on it adam kinzinger is on it
don't remember if there's any other
republicans but at least the two of them
and now you have a situation in which
they by virtue of republicans saying
we're basically opting out of this thing
and at least at the party level we don't
support it even if you found a couple of
our people to be on this committee
now they are actually doing really good
work and exposing incredible things
there was a powerpoint for the coup
all these people who for months have
been doing media saying it wasn't what
it was
on that day knew exactly what it was and
we're texting mark meadows and saying
please help to stop it so it's
excellent that the committee is doing
this
it's exactly the type of insight
infighting and bedlam that we want to
see within the republican party bongino
hannity geraldo
have them all fighting that's exactly
what we want
they will turn on each other to protect
themselves that's abundantly clear if
you say
hey
the riot was inspired by trump which
obviously it was they accused their own
of backstabbing and geraldo is or was a
trumpet i mean he makes it clear even in
that segment the difference is that
hannity and bongino will never admit
that trump did anything wrong geraldo
will admit it and he'll still say he is
or was my friend and i did or do support
him it takes nearly 80 year old geraldo
rivera to apparently realize that what
took place on january 6th was not just
partisan bickering or a rally it was
something much darker and much more
sinister and hopefully this level of
chaos will continue
so okay
we looked in the last segment
at the cognitive dissonance being
experienced by many former and recent
trump supporters because trump stated
the simple fact to candice owens that
vaccines work and they are good and the
people dying of covid disproportionately
are unvaccinated all absolutely true
one of the people triggered by this is
conspiracy theorist alex jones now many
of you emailed me and said david you've
got to cover that alex jones wife was
arrested for domestic violence over the
weekend and uh yes it's hypocritical
that now alex jones says this is private
when
he didn't seem to think that the
specifics of what was going on and the
families of the victims of sandy hook
were private yeah i get the hypocrisy i
don't really care about alex jones
personal life what i do care about is
alex jones now completely turning on
donald trump
alex jones after this candice owens
donald trump interview
came in for a so-called emergency
christmas show
in order to
sound the alarm as he sees it about what
donald trump said
suggesting that donald trump might be
ignorant
he might be evil or he might be both
ignorant and evil and saying that trump
lied in his interview with candace owen
so check this out this is really
it's the stuff of dreams these factions
fighting in this way take a look this is
an emergency christmas day warning to
president trump
you are either completely ignorant
about the so-called vaccine gene therapy
that you helped ram through with
operation warp speed
or you're one of the most evil men who
has ever lived
to push
this toxic poison on the public
and to attack your constituents when
they simply try to save their lives and
the lives of others we're about to lay
out the basic incontrovertible facts
that what you told candace owens just a
few days ago is nothing but a raft of
dirty lies so jones goes on to recite
endless
debunked anti-vaccine lies which i'm not
going to play since i don't want to have
to debunk it piece by piece
but jones does mention that the vaccines
are so-called gene therapies now that's
not true the vaccines don't change your
genes
they don't stay in your body more than a
few days the vaccines are genetically
based therapies they're based on
messenger rna genetic material
the vaccines don't enter the cells of
the nucleus and we could go on but alex
jones is lying and that probably doesn't
surprise you
the most interesting part of this
is the people turning on trump over
something so uncontroversial many
right-wingers will try to soften their
anti-vaccine stances by saying i'm not
against vaccines i'm against mandates
how many times have we heard that
in his interview trump said people
should still have freedom not to take it
but the vaccines are good and the
vaccines work
and he's still getting crushed so all of
the people saying we're only against the
mandates not the vaccines
in the interview trump said i'm not
against i'm not uh for the mandates i'm
just for the vaccine and they're still
going nuts trump said the vaccines are
good and they work and alex jones is
saying this is evil and these are gene
therapies so were they against the
mandates only or are they actually
against the vaccines it seems pretty
clear
as i've said before
the more that these people are fighting
with each other
the less they'll be able to put together
functional 2022 campaigns now my
preference would be
that democrats help themselves in 2022.
it's unclear whether that's going to
happen
so any help that we can get from the
right i will gladly take this also shows
us
that the idea of big tent on the right
is completely bogus if you veer off
script for a day
they come right at you and trump even
tells lies in that clip with candace
owens lies that typically titillate his
followers
but just saying hey the vaccines work
it's mostly unvaccinated people that are
dying it sent a huge portion of his
followers into a tailspin it's hard to
imagine this ends well for them and
that's a good thing it's a sort of
circular firing squad
that is buying more and more ammunition
to use against each other
also
consider how trump said nutty things for
four years and these people were calm he
says vaccines work and they go nuts
trump said what if we nuke a hurricane
he drew with a sharpie on a hurricane
map he said what about injecting bleach
you know i could list 30 things
they're
explaining it all away throughout
trump's presidency trump says vaccines
work and suddenly they implode these are
incredible times that we are living in
the hope is
this damages republicans in 2022. we'll
have these clips on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show make
sure you're following me at david.pakman
as well if you value what we do at the
david pakman show remember to support us
on patreon go to patreon.com david
pakman show where you can get access to
behind the scenes videos the daily bonus
show the commercial free daily show as
well as special discounts on merch
including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show
up here's something really interesting
this is sort of related to the marjorie
taylor green twitter and facebook band
um about
what was it like a month ago three weeks
ago something like that i played a video
clip for you of republican congressman
dan crenshaw who is a trump guy
there's no doubt about it dan crenshaw's
a trump guy
criticizing the so-called freedom caucus
of the house of representatives which is
a very trumpy caucus saying these people
are performance artists and they are not
at the end of the of the day really the
people that voted in support of what
donald trump wanted
this conflict between crenshaw and
people like marjorie taylor greene
is now like two trains barreling towards
each other because after this ban stunt
from marjory taylor green by stunt i
mean how she reacted to it uh dan
crenshaw has much more directly attacked
her and marjorie taylor green has now
turned on him so let let me kind of
explain it all to you
um in the immediate let me get this all
looking correct here in the immediate
aftermath of her being banned
dan crenshaw posted that marjorie
scoffed at the notion of supporting
anti-censorship legislation is
indicative of her true intent to remain
a victim she doesn't want solutions and
she doesn't care if you get censored she
just wants to be a victim so she can
keep asking you for campaign donations
it's a scam
dan crenshaw is 110 correct here he's
110 correct now understand
that what he was advocating for was
seriously heavy regulation of platforms
like twitter and facebook so he is a
hypocrite in the sense that he is part
of the party that says we should do as
little regulation of business as
possible
uh regulating businesses socialism he's
talked on the joe rogan show about his
belief about what socialism is and it's
a very very wrong belief so he was
ignoring his so supposedly sincerely
held beliefs about a light government
regulatory touch saying let's regulate
these companies but he is correctly
pointing out
that marjorie taylor green had the
opportunity to support anti-censorship
as they call it legislation and that
what she is doing is a scam to raise
campaign contributions he's completely
right
he also posted i think this is on his
instagram hey by the way marjorie isn't
this you this was the moment you went
for a few drinks instead of voting on
the ndaa before bringing up miss votes
you might want to check your own record
this is after marjorie taylor green said
to dan crenshaw hey you've missed votes
as well this is a picture of marjorie
taylor greene
sitting at a bar when apparently voting
was taking place on ndaa the substance
of this matters less than the fact that
two pro-trump republicans that's what
they are
are fighting with each other
crenshaw went on to say hey marjorie if
suggesting we should paul follow trump
policy instead of biden mandates makes
you mad then you might be a democrat or
just an idiot so
very big attacks trump on trump violence
crenshaw then posted guess some people
woke up today and tried to compete for
biggest idiot on the internet
uh then going on to say seeing a lot of
manufactured outrage by some people
lately they're worried they're losing
their grip on your attention because
they are
they lash out in the hopes you'll pay
attention to them kind of sad really
dan crenshaw is totally right here about
what marjorie taylor green is doing
these are what we call what i call asbs
attention seeking behaviors and crenshaw
went on to say and marjorie
instead of playing the victim about
censorship
maybe use your position as a legislator
to help pass legislation against
censorship luckily i've already done all
the hard work for you and drafted a bill
that would change section 230 to
prohibit political censorship wanna
co-co-sponsor before i introduce it or
do you prefer to keep up with petty and
childish attacks your call
marjorie taylor green
completely then losing it on dan
crenshaw
saying dan crenshaw is posting creepy
stalking pictures of me referring to the
picture from the bar
and harassing me
to co-sponsor his big tech bill that he
says stop censorship but his bill
actually gives more protection to online
porn companies very very weird thing to
post
and then lastly she wrote
no thanks dan we need to get rid of porn
i am busy reading other republican stop
big tech censorship bills gosh and to
think all of this started when i just
disagreed with him when he said fema
should be doing mass coveted testing and
working in hospitals all i said is no
we don't want fema doing any of that and
hospitals need to hire back unvaccinated
health care workers then poof i'm kicked
off twitter did i offend dan's globalist
friends at the world economic forum
um this is this is really great i have
to tell you guys i wish that the left
was was more competently preparing for
2022
and 2024
i think the left may be heading for
a disaster
but
trump is fighting with trumpists is a
really really good thing and just to
remind everybody here's that original
clip where dan crenshaw seemed to start
expressing some disdain
for the grifters like marjorie taylor
greene and others without naming them
directly remember this supporting these
two
it's actually other veterans and
morgan's race
there's other front runners but why
support these two well because i've been
in congress for almost three years now
there's two types of members in congress
right there's performance artists
there's legislators
now the performance artists are the ones
that get all the intention but the ones
you think are more conservative because
they know how to say slogans real well
they know how to recite the lines that
they know that our voters want to hear
let me tell you guys something in the
first two years of trump's presidency
when republicans were in control when
every single time we were voting on
donald trump's agenda
who do you think was at the top of that
list voting with trump and who do you
think was at the bottom yeah
a lot of names you would recognize were
at the bottom of that list
a lot of things you would recognize are
at the top of that list
number two it's probably going to make
you cringe a little bit it's adam
kensinger
voted
he was number two
so the important thing the important
takeaway here
is that
these are all trumpists in some sense
marjorie t marjorie taylor green is a
trumpist in the way that she has
completely abandoned even talking about
policy
spreads lies disinformation it's kind of
like the cartoonish weaponized trumpist
but what dan crenshaw reminds us
is that a lot of the people that we on
the left might say they're not that bad
liz cheney wow she said biden really won
that's that's really great adam
kinzinger hey he was willing to vote to
convict trump on impeachment
uh i'm sorry uh to uh he he was willing
to support impeachment of donald trump
uh he's a member of the house not the
senate uh and we say wow these people
are kind of more reasonable
they vote with trump all the time all
the time and so they are not our
political allies dan crenshaw is
absolutely right let's hope that this
trump on trump civil war continues
because the left needs something to help
us along this year
on the tuesday show we talked about the
undeniable reality that with the start
of trump rallies um this past weekend
in support of 2022 candidates the 2022
midterms have sort of officially they've
unofficially officially begun
we are now the rallies are starting it's
all starting to happen but there's
another
election
that i normally would not be talking
about right now but i don't think i have
a choice because it's very clear has
also officially begun
the 2024 republican primary has begun
how can you tell you can tell because
donald trump and republican florida
governor ron desantis who previously
were buddies united around covid and
we're all for freedom and ron's doing a
great job opening up for wwe and ufc
when everything else is closed early in
the pandemic they're now attacking each
other and pretty brutally and trump has
even started to send his cronies like
roger stone to attack ron desantis why
ron desantis because ron desantis is
donald trump's primary challenger right
now based on polling for 2022. so let's
go through this uh piece by piece
axios has a report
trump dogs dull desantis
ahead of potential 2024 matchup this is
from jonathan swann
donald trump is trashing ron desantis in
private as an ingrate with a dull
personality and no realistic chance of
beating him in a potential 2024 showdown
according to sources who have recently
talked to trump about desantis why it
matters the two are among the most
popular republicans in the country
as the former president eyes a 2024 run
he is irked by desantis's popularity and
refusal to rule out running against
trump desantis is a favorite of
republican voters when pollsters remove
trump
the governor also hasn't been beyond
tweaking his fellow floridian desantis
said on the ruthless podcast one of his
biggest regrets was not speaking out
much louder
in march of 2020 when trump advised the
american public to stay home
um
this is accurate in the sen what what i
mean is
trump correctly sees desantis as his
biggest foe
for 2024
as of right now we had the cpac straw
poll over the summer
donald trump topped everybody else with
70 percent
but in second place was desantis with 21
that's an informal survey
when you look at the betting markets
where people can bet
who will win the 2024 republican
presidential nomination right now
37 cents of every dollar are being bet
on donald trump and 28 cents of every
dollar are being bet on ron desantis
that's a smaller gap than the straw poll
in july suggested
we also have so-called real polling
there's a harvard caps
harris poll from two months ago where
donald trump was polling 47 percent
among registered republicans and
independents in the primary poll
and that was very far ahead of desantis
who was at 10 percent but again
everywhere you look ron desantis is
running second sometimes it's a pretty
distant second sometimes it's a pretty
strong second so now
trump is starting the attacks and so are
trump's cronies remember this from last
week
here is donald trump in his interview
with oan
calling out ron desantis he doesn't say
his name he doesn't say his name
but it's abundantly clear that he's
talking about ron desantis here as
someone who has gotten the booster and
won't admit it it's something out there
but after now so many months of the
vaccine being administered and these
side effects and americans questions of
it do you reconsider your push for it or
what's your view now on the vaccine in
general well i've taken it i've had the
booster
many politicians i watched a couple of
politicians be interviewed
and one of the questions was did you get
the booster now that that he's talking
about desantis here there's no question
because they had the vaccine
and they oh they're answering it like in
other words the answer is yes but they
don't want to say it
because they're gutless you got to say
it
whether you had it or not say it
but the fact so that is an indirect
attack on ron desantis
um and then also roger stone
has been uh going on uh uh going out
there as trump's uh kind of lap dog for
lack of a better term roger stone
publishing to i think this was on uh
getter or rumble or i don't know who the
hell knows
roger stone saying trump sometimes
sometimes president donald trump hits it
right on the nose ron desantis yale
harvard fat boy can't get out of his own
way not smart not honest and not going
to be president an unknown congressman
with a bad haircut and an ill-fitting
suit until donald trump made him
governor i know where he was when he was
missing ask emerald robinson that's a
reference of course to when ron desantis
was mia for two weeks in the sort of
middle to end of december of last year
we covered that
ron desantis also uh being attacked by
roger stone in a new video that has been
released my beef with governor ron
desantis
ron desantis was an unknown congressman
with a bad haircut an ill-fitting suit
and an undistinguished record in
congress until president donald trump's
endorsement lifted him to the republican
nomination for governor of florida
and then
because ron is such a boring and poor
candidate president donald trump with
the able assistance of susie wiles had
to visit florida twice to drag ron over
the finish line to become governor of
florida
now governor ron desantis refuses to put
his own presidential ambitions on hold
until president donald trump has decided
whether he wants to run again so that's
interesting it's what roger stone is
saying is that the correct thing to do
the respectful thing to do to show
deference to trump would be for ron
desantis to say
this is donald trump's
uh nomination
to turn down
i'm not ruling anything out
but i would not run against him that
would be what roger stone believes would
be respectful i consider that to be an
incredible act of disloyalty and
ingratitude
governor desantis says that i'm a
convicted felon well actually i'm a
former convicted felon thanks to the
pardon by donald trump but if ron
desantis isn't careful he will soon be a
former governor of florida without the
active support of president donald trump
so that's a reference to 2022 because
remember that one of the most
interesting
2022 gubernatorial races
is uh that of ron desantis right and i
don't i want to make sure i'm not
getting that wrong i'd be ron desantis
ron desantis 2022
campaign
um
yes okay yes ron desantis is running um
he's up for reelection in 20 just making
sure i get that right so why are they so
aggressively going after desantis
because they see desantis as a threat
it's very clear that this is 2024
posturing it is not only the trump side
attacking desantis as i told you before
ron desantis saying he wishes that
earlier he would have pushed back
against the things that donald trump was
doing and saying early in the pandemic
mr descen new york times reporting mr
desantis shot back friday
criticizing trump's early handling of
the pandemic
and saying he regretted not being more
vocal
in his complaints
um this is potentially
a fascinating showdown in 2024
and my priority in it is not just the
kind of disaster porn of a really ugly
trump versus desantis primary i would
love that from an entertainment
perspective but at the same time going
from the entertainment side to the to
the important practical matter
i think 2024 is going to be really tough
for democrats if it's trump versus biden
i think trump wins
if it's trump versus kamala harris i
think trump wins if it's desantis versus
biden
i feel less strongly but i still would
lean towards desantis i mean i think
there's a real uphill battle here and of
course there's a lot that needs to
happen the 2022 midterms two more years
of governing and then we will see
but i'm not feeling thrilled about any
of this so what i'm hoping for is that a
really ugly republican primary damages
whoever is the eventual nominee we're
getting very very far ahead of ourselves
but that's the thought process right now
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
i have for you today
one of the craziest political stories
that i have ever covered and it might
not seem that crazy because it has been
slowly building but former vice
president mike pence has now turned on
donald trump publicly in a speech at the
federalist society in florida over the
weekend and donald trump has reacted by
completely losing it on mike pence it is
not normal
that a former president and vice
president just 13 months after leaving
office are in such public conflict
mike pence
publicly now has said
that uh he had no ability or right to
overturn the results of the 2020
election and trump doesn't like that
because trump wanted pence to steal the
election this is part of the growing
civil war in the republican party and
let me tell you clearly and directly
this is not normal it is not normal for
a president and a vice president to have
such major public disagreement so
quickly after leaving office and it is
not over something minor
this is something major the ex-president
says he won
and the vice president could have
flipped the results the ex-vice
president says we didn't win and i have
no right to change the results this is a
disagreement as big as anybody could
imagine dealing with the most
fundamental and crucial elements of how
our democracy is supposed to work let's
go to the clip here is mike pence
president trump said i had the right to
overturn the election
but president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the american
people true and the american people
alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
under the constitution i had no right to
change the outcome of our election
and kamala harris will have no right to
overturn the election when we beat them
in 2024.
all right well listen maybe maybe but
pence is correct in what he is saying
there and donald trump very quickly
completely triggered putting out a
statement saying quote
just saw mike pence's statement on the
fact that he had no right to do anything
with respect to the electoral vote count
other than being an automatic conveyor
belt for the old crow mitch mcconnell to
get biden elected president as quickly
as possible that was one sentence well
the vice president's position is not an
automatic conveyor if obvious signs of
voter fraud or irregularities exist
that's why the democrats and rhinos are
working feverishly
interesting i would describe this
statement as febrile interesting that
trump uses the word feverishly working
feverishly together to change the very
law that mike pence and his unwitting
advisors used on january 6
to say he had no choice the reason they
want it changed is because they now say
they don't want the vice president to
have the right to ensure an honest vote
in other words i was right and everyone
knows it now of course that's not true
the truth about that is
pre-trump there was no disagreement as
to the vice president's ability to to
flip an election
because it even came up in 2020
and the former the now former then
almost former president was pushing
pence to do this there is a move to
strengthen the language to make it even
more clear but the vice president does
not have the opportunity or ability to
change election results trump lastly
says if in other words i was right and
everyone knows it if there is fraud or
large-scale irregularities it would have
been appropriate to send those votes
back to the legislatures to figure it
out the dems and rhinos want to take
that right away a great opportunity lost
but not forever in the meantime our
country is going to hell
folks this is not normal this this
really is kind of like an end of days
type situation which hopefully just
won't actually lead to the end of days
that's that's that's the hope that this
is just okay yeah this is crazy but he's
out of power and he's not going to be
back in power that's the optimistic
scenario now it's very important to
mention at this point
it seems abundantly clear that if trump
does run in 2024 and wins the nomination
his running mate is not going to be mike
pence i can only imagine who it would be
that would be an interesting choice and
i would assume
it would be someone even more radical
than pence now i think there's an
important
disclaimer to make here as far as pence
being the good guy
this is too little too late it has been
13 months since the attempted
insurrection
he was just doing his job and what i
mean by that is
he can't overturn the election it was
crazy that trump even tried to get him
to attempt it pence caused a ton of
damage during his reign as vice
president he said almost nothing about
this until now he doesn't get a medal
pence is horribly toxic he couldn't
overturn the election he didn't choose
not to overturn it he couldn't overturn
it all he's saying now is it's true
i couldn't overturn it imagine not
killing someone in january of 2021 after
your friend urges you your friend goes
please kill this person you don't do it
and then in february of 22
you go i was right not to kill anybody
right murder's illegal you don't get a
cookie for reminding us that 13 months
later uh 13 months later that 13 months
ago you did the only thing you could do
you couldn't overturn the election and
you didn't you don't get a cookie for
that now what's the upside here
the upside is what we're soon going to
discuss
which is that this rift between pence
and trump adds to the republican
fragmentation here's an example here is
uh former trump propaganda stephen
bannon
uh attacking pence over this
pence you're gonna cut you're gonna
carry this thing uh eventually to your
grave okay
because
it is a mark of shame and you are a
stone cold coward
a stone cold coward forest episode we're
gonna start with numbers and analysis
yeah so
pence could have done nothing else the
the only thing
the only thing pence could do
was not try to overturn the election
because he does not have the right or
the power to overturn the election it
was the law
it was the constitution but it's
furthering the rift within the
republican party and i argue that that
is all right let's start today i guess
we're calling this game do you buy it uh
we've talked before about the people who
have sort of softly come out against
donald trump who were previously
associated with them we've also talked
about the people who criticize him but
then when when it really comes down to
it they go i'd vote for him again
earlier this week william barr trump's
former attorney general said the 2020
election stuff trump was saying was bs
he was out of control and he brought out
a clown show of lawyers and then when
savannah guthrie said okay but if he's
the nominee are you voting for him and
he's like well i'm not going to vote for
a democrat
so that's horrifying and disgusting i
have a different example for you today
this is one of donald trump's former
white house press secretaries stephanie
grisham
my opinion
is that he
she rather when it comes to trump
has truly denounced him in a way where
she's saying she's out and here in this
particular clip on the view
uh or no not on the view on some other
show maybe this is the view
she says he's a con man and i'm sorry
and i don't want people to vote for him
what do you guys think but my point is
now i messed up i am sorry i will say
that till that the end of time but i
want to give people an offering and i'm
going to do everything i can to educate
people not talk down to them educate
people about who he really is yeah that
he is a con man that it is a cult-like
thing and that it's okay to just get off
so you would okay it is the view so um
this listen i'm not saying let's go out
and elect stephanie grisham to anything
she's not running for anything as far as
i know but if we're gonna kind of
categorize these things you know michael
cohen who we've had on the show
he
genuinely has denounced trump fully
and uh
is is cooperating to the extent that he
can
to hold trump accountable and i buy that
he he's off the train completely
william barr i mean i think he's trying
to sell books
i think he does recognize trump was nuts
but at the same time he even said i'd
vote for the guy grisham strikes me as
being closer to cohen
then to bill barr with the important
difference that michael cohen has said
i've always been a democrat and i'm back
to being a democrat stephanie grisham as
far as i know is still a republican and
the off-ramp she's talking about is an
off-ramp more than likely
to people like i don't know mitch
mcconnell
mitt romney maybe or who knows what so
i'd put her closer to cohen i do think
she's sincere but at the end of the day
i still don't want her deciding who the
president is let me know your thoughts
what do you think about her level of
sincerity so as we get into the spring
and eventually the summer we're going to
be talking more and more about 2022
primary races and midterm races and just
races in general as many of you know
there's an interesting senate race
happening in ohio this is the race in
which jd vance who is the author of the
book hillbilly elegy which really wasn't
a bad book but he's gone completely off
the rails jd vance is a candidate uh
trumpus josh mandel is a candidate and
at a recent debate within this race
a physical fight almost broke out which
included you guys i'm sure anybody who's
been to a bar
knows these situations
where two i mean it's it's two men i've
never seen women do this at a bar
they start doing the thing where they
puff up it's almost like a peacock or
you know certain animals that kind of
like there's some frogs that like blow
up their chest and certain birds i don't
know if tit mice do it or what kind of
birds
they kind of just start puffing
themselves up and start almost chest
bumping and it's kind of like a a battle
to see who will back down first
that which normally is that happening at
bars
took place at the republican primary
debate it's really really wacky the
times of israel reporting near fight at
ohio republican senate debate between
candidates josh mandel and mike gibbons
after mandel repeatedly interrupts him
gibbons accuses the former soldier
of not knowing how investments work
which was a
that was a fair criticism leading the
latter to stand up and accost his rival
and we have video of this if you're only
listening you'll have to imagine what
it's like although we'll have the clip
up on our instagram and on our tick tock
these are the front runners guys and
we'll look at polling in a moment but
this is how
cartoonish and childish and pathetic
some of these races are check this out
[Laughter]
watch
[Music]
yeah you watch what happens so threats
being issued now i don't know you know
you guys will have to tell me who comes
off as the alpha male in that situation
it's
it's genuinely hard for me to tell and
uh meanwhile jd vance who did not
participate in that but as part of this
race
sat to the side thinking obviously this
really benefits me although he's not
polling that well
these are the front runners in the ohio
republican senate primary we have the
polling here
the latest here is these are average
average average
gibbons is polling 20.
mandel is at 18.7 so that's basically a
tie it's almost within the margin of
error
jd vance is down
at 11
and two other candidate timkin and dolan
are almost where jd vance is
patel with a point and a half so that's
an interesting race and what's
fascinating about it is
the least delusional people
um
well i can't even say that the most
obviously delusional people are some of
the ones doing the best mandel is an
absolute lunatic i mean just a complete
and total lunatic and if you actually go
and look at his um political record you
see that this is uh just a massive
massive um pro-trump guy
and uh he
has backed the election fraud claims of
trump he says that the 2020 election was
stolen
he says if he wins he will carry forward
trump's agenda now what's funny about
that is
it's not clear trump really had an
agenda other than just
self-aggrandizement and and uh you know
putting himself in positions of power he
said the trump impeachment was a sham he
will fight for the america first agenda
he says we will soon see the evidence
coming out of the widespread voter fraud
i mean that that's like a that's
verbatim what trump says
and he's tied for first place
essentially tied for first place with
gibbons so it's a very difficult primary
to kind of make heads or tails out of
because uh so many wacky people in there
and they don't seem to be hurt by saying
and doing crazy things we'll see if the
polling in any way is impacted if
anybody is going to benefit from that
confrontation you would think it would
be jd vance
although there might be republican
voters who like that and you say no i
liked gibbons before and i liked that
gibbons didn't back down or i liked
mandel before and i liked that mandel
didn't back down and they both puffed up
their chests
at this point i don't pretend to know
what republican voters are going to like
but we'll soon see it reflected in the
polling